-So I want to start with this.
You are, obviously, in a very --
reporting on a very difficult
story right now.
You're very composed.
And, yet, I heard on your way
out here, you were at LAX.
And you lost your composure.
-You heard about this?
-Yes.
-So, I ran into Joe Biden.
-Right.
-So the backstory is --
first of all, Joe Biden is like
sitting by himself at LAX,
by himself, 100% by himself,
wearing the aviators
in the corner.
And I'm like,
"That's Joe Biden."
-Yeah.
-So, I'm like, "I got to go talk
to Joe Biden."
The backstory is my
father-in-law in 1987-88
worked on
his presidential campaign.
They were close.
My wife told me, "We hung out
with the Biden kids a lot,
like, great memories."
So I'm like, "I got to go
tell him this."
So I go up to Joe Biden.
I say, "Hey, Mr. Vice President,
I'm Jacob Soboroff from MSNBC.
How are you?"
"Hey, great to see you."
So then I got nervous.
And I said to him,
"My daughter --"
I don't have a daughter.
[ Laughter ]
"i-is my father-in-law's wife."
And I was like -- and then
I said it again.
I was like, "My daughter is
my father-in-law's wife."
And he wasn't responding.
And he kind of, like,
takes the aviators.
And he looks over.
I was like, "Oh,
my wife is my wife.
And my father-in-law
is my father-in-law."
He's like, "Oh, how are they?
Tell them I said hello."
So, I'm sorry,
Mr. Vice President,
if you're watching tonight.
I'll never do that again.
-Yeah, that's like
you were asking him a riddle.
-It was bad.
[ Laughter ]
I was very uncomfortable.
-My wife is my daughter-in-law
is my father.
So who's the doctor?
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-So you actually had been doing,
even before the family
separation policy went in place,
you had been doing a wonderful
piece about the border.
-Yeah.
-And you've been down there.
And you actually spent time
on every mile
of the U.S./Mexico border.
-2,000 miles, yeah.
-Which is incredible.
And you, of course, I think we
all have this image of
the border based on
the news reporting we see.
You actually went down there
and saw a different story
than the sort of
outrageous things
we hear every day on the news.
-It really is unbelievable to me
to hear about how people,
particularly the President,
talk about what is going on
down on the border as if it is
just the most lawless crazy area
you have ever been to.
It's some of the most wonderful
people I've ever met
in my entire life.
Some of the safest cities
in America
are along the southern border.
The idea that drugs are flowing
in where there's no wall
is factually incorrect.
If the President took some time
to read his own DEA reports,
he would know that violence is
not flowing across the border.
He would know that
drugs are coming in
through legal ports of entry.
And he would know that MS-13 is
a tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny percent
of the people that come through.
And the poli-- I mean,
basically they make policies
that rip children away from
their families
and are truly ripping apart
the fabric of society
based on a nonsense.
-Now, you actually, you mention
you met great people.
This was -- This is a true thing
that happened.
Explain what happened.
But this is a man who saw you.
-Yeah, that's true.
-He swam across to you
to offer you...
-Shrimp.
-So, this is the Rio Grande,
where the Rio Grande
meets the Gulf of Mexico.
And that's the very southeastern
most point of the U.S. border.
And this guy calls across to me.
He's like, "Hey, buddy."
And I was like, "Hey."
And he's like,
"Do you want some shrimp?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Yeah, come across.
I'll take some shrimp."
So the guy --
In that cooler also were limes.
And there -- That's
the hot sauce right there.
[ Laughter ]
And so for 5 bucks,
the whole thing,
with the militarized border
and just all this divisive
sort of things,
the guy swam across and just
blew my mind about everything
that we -- you know, you think
you know about what is going on.
So I thank this man very much.
-Yeah.
-It was delicious.
-Well, that -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, you never --
I never once heard Trump say,
"They're sending their shrimp."
-No, no shrimp.
[ Laughter ]
-So you mentioned that the drugs
are actually coming through
the ports of entry that exist.
-Right.
-Based on that, is what
you're saying that a wall,
while, you know,
sort of as a symbol,
seems like a show of strength,
would not actually fix
any of the problems right now
as far as the drug trade goes.
-Yeah, no.
And people shouldn't be
surprised when they --
the President knows this.
It's in the DEA reports
that he gets.
And he continues to say
over and over again.
By the way, it also is not gonna
stop the vast majority of people
that are coming to
this country illegally.
The majority of people that come
into the country illegally
fly here from Asia, for the most
part, and overstay their visas.
And no wall is going to stop
people flying in, you know,
obviously, from Asia.